ايام قلائل تفصلنا عن الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه ومعرفه ما ان كانت البلاد الوجهه
التي ستسلكها خلال الاعوام المقبله سنركز
في هذا العرض على الجوانب الاقتصاديه
والديموغرافيه وارقام لها دلالات في هذه
الانتخابات التركيه نبدا من الليره
التركيه فخلال الولايه الحاليه للرئيس
التركي فقدت اكثر من سبعه وسبعين في المئه
من قيمتها وحسب احصاءات ابريل الماضي
ارتفعت اسعار المواد الغذائيه بنسبه 45%
ايضا نسبه التضخم تجاوزت 43 في المئه كما
ان معدل البطاله في تركيا بقي دون تغيير
عند 10% الزلزال طبعا الذي وقع في فبراير
الماضي زاد من الاعباء على شاغر القصر
الرئاسي اردوغان فوفقا لي تقديرات الامم
المتحده اضرار الناجمه عن هذا الزلزال
ستتجاوز المئه مليار دولار من الجانب
الاقتصادي ننتقل للناخبين الذين سيكون
ثمانيه في المئه منهم هم من الناخبين
الذين سيصوتون لاول مره ويرى الكثيرون
انهم في اكبر مجموعه من الناخبين
المتارجحين نختم مع الفئه الاخرى السوريون
الحاصلون على الجنسيه التركيه الذين يحق
لهم التصويت في هذه الانتخابات نذكر هنا
انه في يوليو من عام 2016 طلب الرئيس
التركي منح جزء من اللاجئين السوريين خاصه
اصحاب الكفاءات العلميه والمهنيه الجنسيه
التركيه وهو ما اقره البرلمان وخلال
السنوات الماضيه حصل
230 الف سوري على الجنسيه التركيه من
بينهم ما يقارب 130 الفا يحق لهم التصويت
في هذه الانتخابات الحاليه الارقام تعني
ان نسبه السوريين القادرين على التصويت في
الانتخابات المقبله من مجموع اعداد
السوريين في تركيا هي
3.66% لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات